in this video i'll show you how the
processing of migrants works here at the
border
we'll also talk to a lawyer so we can
understand the legality behind
the scenes so so yeah the first step
is not testing the first step is just
getting in a holding facility right
right
yeah and this this is the covet testing
you're talking about what's happening
now
is also not helping it's just for show
she doesn't know where she's going she
doesn't know with who she didn't know
nothing
and they fear if they're gonna go back
to their country they're gonna get
killed
i used to actually stay here at the
catholic charities like you said if you
don't see it
directly you'll never know that it's
happening what percentage get denied
okay and who's giving the church the
money to do it they can either take a
decision to go to that court hearing or
disappear into society you know we see
the pictures of the kids sleeping under
tin full blankets they're gonna find
american seeds they're married and
everything's good and that's not true
and they cannot prove their case as a
refugee they're gonna be the boring
that's it
good afternoon guys here in mcallen
texas we have
raul and we have brian and they're going
to bring us into the details on how
migrants how they navigate the united
states
once they get over that wall once they
get on u.s soil
what exactly happens raul lives here
in mcallen knows
it's almost the the migrant path right
they go point a to point
b to point c point d and out while
they're being processed until they get
shipped out where they're gonna get
shipped out to so what's okay so what's
the first
step you know they get uh basically they
get over the border basically they cross
the river
okay come over the border wall or around
the border wall just depending
okay and then once they get apprehended
which they want to get apprehended
because they know they're going to be
released
they get apprehended by border patrol
they get brought into
the holding facility over here in
downtown texas
from that donna that donna facility they
get processed and whatever they're going
to do
that's a massive facility right it's a
huge facility right now it's
there's close to 5 000 people in that
facility okay so once they get processed
in that facility
they're brought to mcallen to what i
call is tent city
okay that's where they do the kova tests
and stuff after the covet testing
if they're negative they go a little bit
farther down a few blocks over to the
to the and this this is the picture this
is the covet testing you're talking
about yes
right so just to be straight they come
over they
they put their hands up or whatever and
and uh border border patrol says okay
you're coming with us
yes they go on a bus they go to the big
facility for how many days the donna
facility
donna it's about three day process okay
but depending right now they're a little
bit backtracked due to the amount of
people they have in there so
okay but normally it's like a three-day
process okay and then
they don't know if they have coveted
then or not right they get tested after
that three day process after they're
done from there they ship them over here
where they get tested over here
and this is over here this is in my
common factory the next step
okay and so they come into this facility
get tested now if they're if they're
positive
what happens they're positive they get
shipped to san juan or to uh
someone some of the hotels that are
being paid for by the government okay so
they're both they're funding hotels for
them that way they can go ahead and uh
stay there in quarantine in a hotel room
okay with no supervision or anything so
nothing to stop them from leaving
that hotel okay so in the hotel how many
days
as far as i know they're renting it for
seven days for seven days and then after
the seven days what happens exactly
they find out where their families are
at or whatever they're gonna do
they'll get them bus tickets they'll
give them a packet with the information
from the government saying you know
they're allowed to roam freely
throughout the united states some are
giving a court date are not okay the
reason why i say some or not they're
holding back that process
to to speed up stuff okay what if they
come in here
and are negative if they're negative
they're like they're gonna come down
south
about two blocks over okay we're to go
there right
yes okay we're on our way that way right
now on the left side of catholic charity
there's uh i mean on the left side of
the south station sorry
if they're negative they go directly to
the catholic charity yes
everyone yes okay
i gotta say this is this is very
hard content to make because it's such a
it's such a polarizing complex difficult
issue i remember when i was in my
younger 20s
i was living in durango colorado and
there was this family
in the in the entry we have a grocery
store and they obviously didn't know
what they're doing or where they were
going
and uh i put them up in a hotel for
a week i didn't know their their story
or anything other than i was a human and
i wanted to help
um so i see the humanitarian side of it
and then i see the were a system of laws
and people have tried to immigrate for
many years
legally into the country and why should
someone
um be able to just come in
if you open the borders completely you'd
have
millions and millions and millions of
people from all over the world coming
because that's just how the world works
it's uh people go where the
opportunities are it's always worked
that way it always will work that way
uh yeah i'm not giving you a clear
answer
and i'm and i don't want to to be honest
uh
it would be easier just to give you a
it's black and white
and that's not fair and it's not honest
of course i have my bias from my
experiences in life living overseas
and traveling a lot of the world the
thing i come back to and i love about
the us
is how things work and how there's law
most are coming i don't know all their
stories
i want to talk to a migrant it's really
freaking hard
i don't think it's going to happen but
most of the stories are
you know people running from bad
situations obviously and i'm sure
there's
there are all sorts of stories like
cartels
human trafficking these things are all
happening at once
so i could show a story of a kid that's
in down and out and that's a true story
and i can show
the cartel member who's benefiting off
the border patrol not being able to
really do much these days
um having their hands tied being
overwhelmed
and that's a true story too so so yeah
the first step
is not testing the first step is just
getting in a holding facility right
right
yeah these tests these tests basically
tell
if they had it before when they came
over
right right but they go into a facility
crowded together with a bunch of people
for three days
and they come out and get tested the
test will catch if they were already
positive
okay but then the people that test
negative could be could be holding the
virus
it just hasn't hasn't shown up yet let
them go
and they can test positive later but
they're never going to be tested again
okay how long has this been going on for
raul like this setup
as we see here this tent city right here
just started after
the mcallen bus station it came out that
they transported 150 people
that were coveted positive so right
after that they made a big deal about
the bus station
okay so they made it mandatory that they
get slips and you know what they are
covered negative before they're allowed
into their buses
so this is the charity yes and that's
one of the white vans waiting to
transport people from here to the from
here to the airport
okay so if they're covered negative into
the charity
and then in a van out to the airport or
to the bus station
right here okay so those will be going
to the airport okay
and then where do they where are they
going wherever their destination is
whether it's california new york
chicago they get to choose they get to
choose because basically they're saying
you know what i have family in new york
and they look up their family and they
give them a call and whatever and
and coordinate whatever they're going to
coordinate they provide ice like the
name and address of somebody in the u.s
and they buy them either a bus ticket or
a plane ticket most of them from mcallen
are going directly to dfw and that's
where they're spreading out from
there okay so they can choose wherever
they want to go what if someone doesn't
have a connection let's go across the
street guys well that's what i heard
about three days ago and that's what we
need to check into
there's this one girl who said you know
what the catholic church found my family
in california
uh-huh but when when my people asked her
do you have people in california she's
like i don't know
okay and so she said well how do you
know that you're gonna actually go to
your family
and she's like they talked to him they
they arranged it
they gave him my ticket i'm going to
california she doesn't know where she's
going she doesn't know with who she
didn't know nothing
all she knows is the catholic charity
found
their family okay and they're on their
way that way but yes she never spoke to
their family at all so who knows where
she's actually going
i used to actually stay here at the
catholic charities
one day when it was really cold out
they decided to say y'all
because y'all like to smoke and y'all
like to drink
and we don't like that yeah but yet they
have an employee that's sitting there
bitching that we need to make america
mexican again and he's sitting there
smoking pot
all right so you you were in you were in
this you were staying in this charity
and they said you had to leave yep but
you were you were smoking and doing
right yeah but i wasn't smoking in there
okay i was following all the rules
they told me if i come in and i look
high i can't stay
how about how many people did they kick
out beside you
in total i'd say they kicked out
roughly 60 to 70 homeless people and
they're all american citizens
as far as i know they're all american
citizens
there's even an older gentleman who's
missing a leg
who was in a wheelchair and they kicked
him out the streets
and did they give you a reason why they
kicked you all out they said it was
because of our drug habits
i'm like so what we have drug habits
you don't know what's going on in our
lives it makes us choose drugs
just let it stay here do you want to get
do you want to get off drugs
yeah you do if someone who came through
and was like we're going to help you
get off drugs would you be down or you'd
be like that really
what are you on what's your go-to stuff
going spice
what's that hey you know what that is
fake marijuana ah
yeah no but it's worse than it's worth
marijuana yeah what do you mean it's
just
it's authentic weed so what happens all
the chemicals in there to get you hooked
on it like that
what happens all these little smoke
shops they used to sell that stuff
i don't know if they still do but yeah
they used to sell that stuff they do
yeah they used to sell that stuff
that thing is nice it's more it's with
all the different chemicals in there
i said they sometimes they'll kill you
right off the bat or it's highly
addictive
yep they can put fentanyl opiates heroin
whatever they want on it they even spray
raid
raid like the uh repellent yeah roadster
they put rat poison what they'll use
anything in it
it's more profitable that way huh yeah
super chemicals cheaper chemicals all
right i was gonna say it's more
profitable
to just stick the camera out there sneak
an interview
or you go in there you should do it make
a video
if i could get into that man i would sit
there and i'd make them actually
question their religion
how much are you gonna pan they'll
change their damn they'll change their
ways
take care man all right good luck get
off that stuff
he was talking about here he's talking
about the doorbell get off that stuff
that's gonna kill you
all right how how are the people
in the community feeling because an
interesting fact about being here in
mcallen for the last few days is
if you don't talk to a guy like you
i would have no idea anything's going on
if streets the streets are normal
it's not like you see this chaos or
anything on the streets you don't
the city looks normal basically
everything functions as normal
okay like you said if you don't see it
see it directly
you'll never know that it's happening
and that's that's why we need to get
people to know that you know what there
is a problem
like it doesn't only affect mcallen uh
the county of hidalgo or the state of
texas
right it affects everybody in general
because these people get sent all over
the united states
and somehow or another taxpayers are
paying for that whether it's their
their tickets their shelter like
the hotels that they're putting up for
and once they get here
then the church is covering them their
their initial expenses at least right
exactly
okay and who's giving the church the
money to do it the government is
ah i'm sorry to say but the church sold
themselves
and it's not the first time but they've
sold themselves because
it's a money maker
all right guys so i'm here with my good
buddy
and former immigration lawyer friend
raphael mariano and raphael's brought me
through
some of the basics here which i had no
clue about um
i think most people don't have any clue
about unless they've been in you know
what you've done
understand the process so rafa walk us
through like the legal process
if someone comes over through a port of
entry and they're
you know they they get into the united
states legally like you did
um there's a very clear legal process
that they take right
correct but if somebody goes through a
non-port of entry like crosses the river
gets apprehended by border patrol a lot
of them are not getting sent back
it's hard to know the exact number um i
saw with my own eyes and that if you
look at the
customs and border protection the
numbers are way up correct what's that
so
they're seeking asylum correct and
that means they're not legal in the
united states or they're illegal until
they're court hearing
or or walk us through how that works so
this is
another complicated process right this
is the asylum process right
so that means is if you're seeking
asylum yeah
you can try to cross and you say you you
basically
you intentionally you're caught right
say hey look i'm here i'm seeking asylum
right
okay to do that you're gonna have to
prove that you're a refugee
that your situation fits on the
refugee status and requirements of
course the officer there
you're not gonna need to prove to him
right you can't that's not
that's not a duke process right right
you're gonna say look i'm here to seek
asylum
right so take me and and usually
you know i believe what's happening now
supposedly i
i don't know so what used to happen is
you get caught
your process right yeah and you are
staying your way
right and the other two why they happen
because
you cannot seek asylum while you are
still in your country
okay that's not how the process works
you you only can seek asylum of course
there are exceptions and i i'm not
we don't have a year here for me to go
through everything right yeah yeah give
us the
give us the quick um the quick play by
play points let's say because
like in all the research i've done the
further you get down this rabbit hole
it's just
a whole after rabbit hole and you can go
in and like it's a full
lifetime of yeah it's huge so you're
here present yourself
yeah i'm a refugee i'm seeking asylum
your process
and whatever you're seeing your way
inside of the u.s
you have a court day right okay so
you're not legal
at all you are a silent seeker right
you're right but until your court date
you have papers saying you're legal to
be in the united states
yes i believe they give you yes because
you're gonna have your process you're
gonna have a
paperwork explaining your situation with
your court date right
the court date it is not a legalization
day
right it's really is a court day for you
to be there and prove
that you are in fact a refugee
it is a really high burden right
you have to prove because you are
alleging that you are
refugee seeking seeking as i don't right
so you stand in front of the judge
at the court you have to have evidence
obviously and then what
yeah what percentage of these people
seeking asylum
you know what percentage get denied yes
so can i just
really quickly tell you what you need to
prove because that's important because
it's hard right
so you need to prove that you're a
refugee so to do that
you have to fulfill some requirements
what are the requirements you have to
prove
that you are being um persecuted in your
country okay okay and you are being
prosecuted because specifically those
factors
because of race because of religion
because your nationality because your
political opinion
or because you belong to this specific
social group suffering discrimination
or prosecution in your own country and
it's hard right you need to have
witnesses documents showing that so
because of that this is an average right
i'm just telling you like a total number
a total percentage of
asylum applications that are denied okay
varies between 65 to 70 percent
so so is is high right so basically
uh like we think ten applicants
approximately only three are approved
can prove their case the the the
migrants that come over that spend all
the money
to the cartels and the coyotes and the
smugglers and all that
to get over they spend all their money
and then
there's no guarantee once they sort of
have a little window getting into the us
where like okay we can breathe and relax
now we're legal here
legal until the court hearing protect it
yes
but then by going to the hearing the the
like the problem the probability that
you're gonna get
sent back home is high super high
all right so so how how long
and this is a really difficult part
about this i want to explain to the
audience here guys
you know the more i research in this
this is rabbit hole after rabbit hole
there's one website everything is
politicized with this topic
there's no way around that except this
one site i found track immigration
who knows but from what i saw they say
they're independent and nonpartisan
but that's the website i also want to
aim people towards like
we're touching the basics here and we
have to keep it short for a youtube
video but it's
if you want to get in i find like the
metrics really break down so
the people that say 99
of uh migrants go back to their court
hearing
uh well when you start breaking apart
those numbers
you realize well these are case studies
specific areas we're not talking as like
a national hole
and then and then the people that say 99
avoid their asylum hearings i don't
think those are correct numbers either
so it's really hard in itself just to
get the right numbers
because the immigration court records
are secret also this is what i read
um so the government statistics are
difficult to verify in this
but just from a common sense level i
would think all right
i made all that effort i spent all that
money and if i go to court
and the probabilities i'm going to get
sent home
probably wouldn't want to go but i don't
want to aim that argument what do you
what do you think on that like
so you're so short so for my look i saw
a lot of people
who are seeking asylums right and that's
the difference right
the immigrants that are really here as a
refugees
they will attend the court because they
have a valid case
and and they fear if they're going to go
back to their country they're going to
get killed
or sent to jail forever right or will
disappear
so i i do not know the numbers like you
said it's very hard to find the real
statistic how many of those people that
enter here then attend their hearing i
don't know
what i know is the law is clear if you
are here
as a refugee seeking asylum
for a year or more you can never again
go to the core and make sure you have
the asylum status
that's it you have one year inside of
the us
to fix your situation what if the courts
are backed up like now because i read
there are 400 asylum judges
and they're they're just backed up and
especially with this recent surge like
the processing is probably falling
behind i can imagine well but that
that's not their fault right that's okay
we'll start their process
right within the year it's just that the
court date
may not be within a year or sometimes
everything a year but that is continued
because of that but that is not their
fault right
right what's going on is if you enter
and then you wait
maybe you miss your court or maybe you
don't do anything for a year and then
you say hey i'm gonna you know what i'm
gonna do my
my process make sure i i am a refugee
illegally
if you pass that here that's it you will
deport it
and i just really want to make clear to
you guys you know getting into this
whole border situation i i'm almost
embarrassed as a
as an american didn't know really
anything about it until recently
didn't start putting any attention
towards it until i went there
and um what you realize is
well what i thought was if someone what
i was told to a few times was if someone
got in
seeking asylum like they're legal to be
in the u.s but no you're telling us
no it's just a window of time and then
they can either take a decision to go to
that court hearing or
disappear into society yeah and be
illegal
correct and that's the thing if you miss
your hearing
from the bench the judge will issue a
deportation order
okay for you and then if you get caught
if they find you
that's it you'll be deported and then as
i
i explained before when you're deported
you're not going to
come back here even if you have visa
there is something they're going to say
because a lot of people don't know that
if you enter here illegally
we found inspection and then you know
and then you live your life you work you
met
a american citizen and you get married
and you think
wow now i will be able to legalize my
status
right and and be able to become a
resident and then a citizen
if you're married to an american you're
in or you should be right
yeah yes but a lot of people think that
that's the goal they're going to find
american citizens marry and everything
everything's good and that's not true
if you enter illegally we found
inspection with our visa
even if you marry the american citizen
as soon as you start your process right
your immigration process when your
petition is approved
you will be deported back to your
country
and you will have if you are in the
country for over
180 days illegally
you will be sent back to your country
with a mandatory ban to enter again
for 10 or 20 years
that's a few okay if you marry the
american
even if you marry america you're gonna
be in your back
you're gonna have to do a consular
process in your
own country but as a punishment because
you committed a crime right
you're gonna be there for 10 20 years
until you and then your petition may be
approved but look
more likely than not you're done once
you're out
they're not gonna be you know they're
not gonna be allow you back and do you
think your marriage you survive 10 20
years
your wife lives in the u.s and you're
living outside of the country
right all right that's a reality that
nobody
really knows see so
okay as you can see guys it's the the
deeper you go in
uh and rafa told me like what do you
want like a week to talk about this to
get it to understand it and
i said no short synopsis so
that's that's that's it's it's so
complex right what is you what are your
thoughts rap i'd like to close this
close this up here and there's no simple
solution there's no
uh you know cure but what do you what do
you say
what would be the right way to do it i
i don't think anyone knows is look we
have good loss
in the u.s we we do have laws
but but the problem is you know we have
the problem of enforcement
of those laws we have the problem of
controlling the border
so really the problem is manpower
in courts processing your immigration
paperwork and on the border and i really
don't know if we as a country have
appetite
for to spend that kind of money resource
to fix that issue i really don't know
i i don't see a clear solution i think
that's
what about the migrants i was told um
you know migrants when they come into
the states well what i saw firsthand
were they were given issued plane
tickets
the catholic charity was funding um
their stay and food and clothes stuff
like that
now when they get they growing all over
the country right now it's not like
they're staying in mcallen texas or
these border cities
like they're getting distributed you can
go on the planes right you're going
from mcallen to dallas and they're
migrants on there with little
pamphlets saying they don't speak
english and they're given all their
documents
what's happening now is also not helping
the asylum seekers it's just for show
because those people the best case
scenario you know 70 percent is going to
be denied
[Music]
you're saying like the what's going on
now is not helping
the asylum seekers i mean it's helping
right now right i mean for this
immediately is helping them because they
are not in their country right
that's helpful they are here but long
term
i don't think it's going to help them
because they're going to have to go
through the process
so if they show up in court and they
cannot prove their case as a refugee
they're going to be deported that's
it and and you know per the statistics
only 3 out of 10 is going to be legit
they're going to be able to prove their
case
right you know and all the rest is going
to be the part and then it's crew
then they're never going to unless
there's a change in the law like amnesty
is granted
yeah unless that's the unless that's the
plan that they're saying look we're
gonna let
whatever is the number a million people
get in
and then as soon as we reach that number
i'm gonna assign the asylum
regarding everybody that is here as long
as you don't write because i
asylum just sorry honesty
just work if you never committed a crime
also you have that there are a lot of
government resources
federal resources and i think state
resources probably going towards
these people that might get sent back
most likely will if they go to court
yeah um
[Music]
i was told food stamps but i think
that's a federal thing i think you have
to be a u.s citizen for
food stamps how much do you think is
being spent
and you don't have to have a number but
as far as what you saw
with the people you your clients you
were representing
how much was the system paying for their
lives here in the us
so that's that's the thing i i'm not
really sure what's happening
right now inside of the system right
when i was representing
uh immigration clients right they
they were receiving zero assistance from
the u.s government there was no
assistance that they think
what the no no playing tickets so bus
tickets your process
and you are let go and then you just
have to attend your court
hearing but at that time they are not
controlling where you
go they don't give you because if you're
not a us
uh citizen you don't really qualify for
any
um government assistance like i i'm
i am an immigrant i was never an illegal
immigrant
but when i was i am a u.s citizen now
but when i was a only a u.s resident
what that means is when you have a green
card
i would never qualify for any government
assistance i was i was paying taxes yeah
but i will not qualify for you know
social security or any government grant
or
anything so i'm not sure what's
happening now
so i know now they at least from what i
saw from account they're getting plane
tickets bus
tickets and i was rumored a card with a
certain amount of money on it 800 to
1200 but i can't verify that
um i need to spend you know once getting
over because these people are coming
over with like nothing
by the for sure by that point they've
spent oh much money to get over
i don't think they're coming with much
um but also
something and this could actually turn
into a freaking podcast raffa because
there's so much to talk about but
they're not legal so if they're here for
a year
these these migrants and they're not
they're not legal like until they're
court hearing and that goes through the
system
then how are they making money you know
they're going to have to work illegally
right isn't that the only way
to make money yeah it is i mean
if you are here in limbo statues right
and you don't have a social security you
don't have a work permit or anything
you cannot legally work you can't
you're gonna have to work right
illegally which is also a crime
and then when you start your immigration
process you're going to be punished by
issue
it's going to be a financial fee the u.s
government
will apply to you and you have to pay
what do they what do they expect how are
people supposed to live a year without
working and making money exactly that's
what i'm saying
the solution is tricky because nobody
wants military resolve that for sure why
because those
people and i know because i had a lot of
clients like they are working they are
working illegally but
a lot of people don't talk about that
they are also paying taxes yeah because
usually they are using a different name
or a fake social security number
so the us government it is collecting
taxes
and those taxpayers are not collecting
their refund
right so there is a free money for the
us government
it's like how crazy is that that the
system with social security numbers
isn't set up correctly where
someone can get a social security number
who is not a citizen or not legal here
and then out of their paycheck money
goes towards
the federal government and the federal
government takes it in
the the worker gets none of the you know
tax back or any you know none of the
rebates of the
new year or anything correct and then
everyone just pretends or what what's
going on there
correct everybody pretends and is a free
basically i know the u.s spend a lot of
money with the processing and you know
and
and managing those prisons and the
airplanes and all
but also they i i think it's my just my
little observation but what the u.s
gained
gained very cheap labor yeah and
basically gained
free tax money then nobody will ever ask
for a refund
so you know and i don't know what are
those numbers
that would be a very good error to
research and see well how much we are
really making
yeah with that and how much you are
spending you know i don't know
all right you want to close on anything
rafa anything else you want to say here
no i'm just saying that i i don't know i
really feel bad
for for all those people you know that
are
legitimately coming here and try to
improve their lives
and you know risking their lives and i
really i don't know
what is the solution that we work for
everybody
i feel bad for all parties involved i
feel bad for customs and border patrol
calling themselves true considers now
because they're taking care of kids and
can't do their job i feel bad for the
migrants coming from bad situations
uh i feel bad the overall situation that
we we're like
incentivizing criminality
you know with bad actors doing you know
because customs is so burdened
you know there's there's the opportunity
now human trafficking
drug trafficking all this stuff and
and a lot of people talk about the ice
agents right the
the officers there that are risking
their lives true some of them get killed
but it's not easy work out there not
and uh don't worry i'm sure our
politicians will fix us in the next
couple years because they do
care about all of our best interests
we're all sick all right robin thank you
and oh in closing here i want to stay to
the audience here rafa is the
the quintessential american dream he was
a
a soap actually it's a little different
one he's a soap opera star actor in
in brazil then had to basically hit the
floor
cleaning hotel rooms in reno nevada uh
your first job and the mexican cleaners
that were with him
were uh starstruck because they couldn't
believe their favorite actor was
cleaning alongside them that's true and
then he
that he worked up and now he has his own
law firm so it's a beautiful story
and thank you my friend thank you rafa
for
for being part of this and uh explaining
a little more behind the scenes
thank you for being my friend man so i
just want to mention guys you don't just
you just don't show up in mcallen texas
and and get into the scenes with a
camera
uh i'm only doing so because i'm lucky
enough the united
cajun navy reached out to me both raul
and brian are part of the organization i
want to make a distinction
united because there are many cajun
navies this is the united
cajun navy and you guys basically do
disaster relief hurricanes tornadoes
yeah most people know us as like search
and rescues because that's
that's what they've seen on the news
right flood water rescues things like
that
but we've come we've become more of a
logistical organization we have
warehouses back in louisiana
people donate a lot of supplies and a
lot of
a lot of different things and we just
basically we partner with people who
have trucks and
and they come pick it up and take it out
to areas where it's needed and
you know we were reached out to um
saying that there was supplies needed
here on the border and we weren't really
sure what was going on or why it was
needed
we were just told it was a humanitarian
crisis so uh last month uh i came down
myself and hooked up with raul to see
what was going on and
you know we see the pictures of the kids
sleeping under tinfoil blankets and we
have a lot of blankets that were donated
by american airlines for the recent
freeze over the winter
and so we were like okay who can we send
supplies to who can distribute it for us
thanks for bringing me in and and
especially real living here and
educating me on what's going on in the
ground
thank you i'm trying get this out there
let everybody know that you know what it
is a problem
and it is going to affect everybody in
the long run gotcha
all right until the next video
you